[THEME MUSIC]
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi
and welcome to episode
number 153 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Melanie Warrick,
and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hi, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi, Melanie.
We are changing things
up a little today.
MELANIE WARRICK: We are changing
things up a little today.
So it was a really
rough week last week,
and this is our second
time doing this,
because it really hit
us hard, a lot of things
that played out last week.
So we decided today,
as a change of pace,
we're going to talk about
some different organizations
that you can donate to if you
are feeling the way we do.
Because I know both of us
have felt very angry, and sad,
and all kinds of things.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
have all the things.
I think the thing
that comes to my mind
is when I talk to our
mutual friend, KF,
and she says she's "in a mood."
I think that's an appropriate
way to describe it.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: We do have
our interview for the week.
We have Tony Aiuto, who is
going to talk to us about Bazel.
And so we will talk about that.
And then we're going
to end it, and we'll
talk on some of the
up-and-coming stuff,
the Cool Things of the Week.
But as I mentioned, we
do want to recognize
a lot of the things that
have played out last week.
And it has impacted
us in our own ways.
So if you want to
take any action,
and especially if you want to
donate to different causes that
can help people who
are disadvantaged,
it's my nice couching
word for all the things,
there's a couple different
groups like Time's Up
Now, which is a
legal defense fund.
That's a place where
survivors of sexual harassment
or abuse in the workplace
can get the legal help
and public relations
support they
need to take back their
power, seek justice, and make
their voices heard.
There's also Project Alloy, or
also known as Alloy Alliance,
and they give financial
grants and other resources
to people who are early in
their career, underrepresented
in tech.
And this is a way to give them
financial resources especially
to go to conferences and go to
events that allow them to get
access and network
with them the industry
and find opportunities.
And then there's the
MeToo STEM, which
provides resources
to graduate students,
postdocs, and women who have
been hurt by sexual harassment.
And so that one is definitely
a very valuable resource that's
just up-and-coming.
And so these are all options.
If you know of others, feel
free to tweet at us, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that'd be lovely.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then I want to give--
Mark, you had a few others,
especially in relation to what
happened over the weekend.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
With the recent shooting in
Pittsburgh at the synagogue,
I wanted to mention HIS, which
is a Jewish organization that
helps refugees worldwide
of any ethnicity,
basically rescuing people whose
lives are in danger, basically,
who they are.
So if you are able to
donate to a cause like that.
There's also the
Anti-Defamation League, which
is another Jewish organization.
They've been fighting
anti-Semitism
and hate since about
1913 worldwide.
If you are looking
for, say, a vigil
or gathering for the shooting
that happened in Pittsburgh,
they do have a map
and schedule of those
there right there
on the website.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
The other thing I
wanted to mention,
this is something that matters
a lot to me in particular,
is there's a very established,
well-known AI academic
conference, or machine
learning academic conference,
however you want to
view it, and they
do all the things in the
research space around this.
Neural Information
Processing Systems,
we've talked about this
conference in the past,
they did this whole
research this past year
and came out with
the results last week
on whether they
were going to change
the name of the conference,
because NIPS as an acronym
has been very much viewed
as an offensive acronym.
Because they've chosen
based on their research
to not move forward with that,
which many in the community
feel disappointed and many
other feelings around this, one
of the wonderful advocates
in the space, and I'm so bad
at pronouncing names, but
[? Adama Anunkumar, ?]
who is the director of
machine learning research
in [INAUDIBLE],, she's also a
brand professor at Caltech,
she has started a petition
that we will link.
And if you want to
help show your support,
please sign this petition.
And I think, Mark, you wanted
to say a couple more things?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I just wanted to say
it's been a really
rough week for Jewish people.
It's been a really rough week
for trans and binary people.
There's been several things
around women's rights
that have also happened,
and sexual assault.
MELANIE WARRICK: There was
bombs being sent to people.
I mean--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's been a really rough week.
MELANIE WARRICK: It has been.
MARK MANDEL: So please
take some time for yourself
if you need it.
Get any self-help or self-care
that you need to take.
Take care of yourself.
Take care of your loved ones.
If you have people in your
life that you love, tell them.
I think-- we were
talking about before,
life is a bit
fleeting sometimes.
So make sure you
take care of yourself
and the people around you.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, definitely.
And I'm also going to
make those plug again
that if you're in
the US, please vote.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
What we are going
to do is transition back
into our regularly--
MARK MANDEL: Yep,
scheduled programming.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--schedule programming.
And so we will go and talk to--
MARK MANDEL: Tony.
MELANIE WARRICK: --Tony,
thank you, about Bazel.
So let's go do that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds great.
So I'm very excited today to
have Tony Aiuto joining us
today, the engineering lead
for Bazel Product Excellence,
to talk to us all about Bazel.
How are you doing today, Tony?
TONY AIUTO: I'm good, thanks.
How are you guys?
MARK MANDEL: Doing well.
Doing well.
TONY AIUTO: Good.
MARK MANDEL: It's Wednesday.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's Wednesday.
MELANIE WARRICK:
No, it's Thursday.
MARK MANDEL: It's Thursday?
TONY AIUTO: It is
Thursday in New York.
MARK MANDEL: That explains why
we didn't have bacon at work.
There we go.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're right.
You're on Thursday,
we're on Wednesday.
Clearly this country
has gotten much bigger.
MARK MANDEL: I don't
know what day it is.
Cool.
Well, I remember this.
Today we're going
to talk about Bazel.
That is the thing we're
going to be talking about.
MELANIE WARRICK:
You are correct.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
But before we do that,
Tony, why don't you
tell us a little about
who you are, what you do.
What do you do here at Google?
TONY AIUTO: I've been at
Google for about 10 years.
I've worked on a
variety of things,
and was [INAUDIBLE]
Blaze, the predecessor
of Bazel for a long, long time.
And I switched over
to the Bazel team
recently to try to get a
handle on making it a quality
open-source product.
So I sit at the intersection
between the engineering
team, that sees it as
an open-source project,
and end users who really
don't care provenance of it.
They just want something
that all works together
with a certain level of
reliability and polish.
And so that's my role in there,
trying to bridge that gap.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
Tony, I know you're here
to talk to us about Bazel.
What's Bazel?
TONY AIUTO: OK.
"Basel."
"Basil."
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I was going to say,
I'm Australia-American--
I'm going to say "Basil," but
you're going to say "Basel."
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, I love it.
"Toh-mah-toh, toh-may-toh."
OK.
TONY AIUTO: Right, yes.
Well, our logo before
the stylized cubes
was really a basil plant.
MELANIE WARRICK: Ah.
TONY AIUTO: And half our team is
in New York, half is in Munich,
so we get both pronunciations.
So I'll accept either.
Everything's good.
But the origin of it is it
sprung from Google's internal
build system, which
is called Blaze.
And "Bazel" is an anagram
of "Blaze," in that sense.
Blaze started about 10
years ago-- eh, probably 12,
at this point,
years ago at Google.
And we've been using it for all
our builds during that time.
And it's gone through a series
of iterations and rewrites,
from Python, to Java, and
added this extension language.
At one point, we decided
to open source it
and make the Bazel project,
sort of giving back
to the community.
And we're finding it's a whole
new bit of work to do that.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds right.
So at a high level, what
does Bazel actually do?
What's the thing it does?
TONY AIUTO: It is a--
at a very high level,
it's a build system you can
really make with Autotools,
or CMake, or Gradle, or Maven,
but places a different focus
from the ground up.
In that we want to be able to
build across multiple languages
and orchestrate
very large builds,
and run the tests for them
in a very repeatable way.
Our focus is on fast and
accurate in a pick two.
We want to do incremental
builds at speed.
That requires having
a very well-defined
build so that we know exactly
what to build incrementally.
And then we can tie
Bazel into systems
to get remote build execution
and caching of results,
so that we can really make
a team faster by reducing
the time it takes
to do their builds.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
In terms of Bazel/Basil, what
makes it different, though,
from other options
that are out there?
TONY AIUTO: At the bottom,
the key is that all of our
build steps are hermetic.
We always know what
goes into something
and what comes out of it.
And essentially,
we hash the inputs
to any rule and the
hash the resultant thing
so we can cache it very well.
You've built C applications.
You know that you
include a .H file,
and it will get
it from somewhere.
That doesn't happen
in Bazel builds.
You always know where you're
getting all the inputs to your
build.
So that tactical, strategic
decision at the bottom
allows us to get
reproducible builds,
and very precise, incremental,
builds that you don't get,
let's say, with make-based
things and shell scripts
gluing stuff together.
We also [INAUDIBLE] all
the languages at once.
So we don't have to
change build systems
in the middle of [INAUDIBLE]
native code for an Android app
with one set of
tools, and then bundle
that up and then use, let's say,
Gradle to build the Java parts.
MARK MANDEL: So how many
languages does it actually
support?
TONY AIUTO: That's
a good question.
There are probably
around 40 rule sets
that we track right now.
Some of them are on
the Bazel build site
and the GitHub project there.
Others are
independently developed.
But the big ones are C++,
Java, Python, Go, JavaScript,
C# and .NET, Scala.
There's Dart, and Kotlin,
and Swift, and Rust,
and Ruby too, and others
I haven't even named.
And orthogonal to that, we
talk about platform support.
So we want to be able to build
in any of those languages,
and then deliver to
Docker, or Kubernetes,
or to different
execution platforms.
One of the other important
Bazel distinctions
is that we separate the
notion of the platform you're
building on from where
you're going to deploy it.
So we were very clear in
the semantics of, well,
I happened to be building on
a Windows machine code that's
going to be deployed on a Linux
server or an Android phone.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, as a developer,
how do I use Bazel?
What does it look like
when I'm working with it?
TONY AIUTO: It's not too
different than other things
you're used to.
We have build files, which
are equivalent to a Make file,
or a Gradle configuration,
or a CMake files.text.
Inside it are a bunch of
definitions of targets.
We don't really have executable
code in the build files.
We want them to be very
declarative, rather than
procedural.
So we define targets, and
each one is the name of it,
the sources that go into it,
and the dependencies it has.
But from a developer's
point of view,
they sprinkle the build files
around [INAUDIBLE] their code,
and will run Builder Blaze
test with a set of targets--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TONY AIUTO: --and
the things happened.
MARK MANDEL: Is it Bazel
build, or is it Blaze build?
Or you-- you've historically--
TONY AIUTO: No,
it's a Blaze build.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you have
historical Freudian slips.
TONY AIUTO: That happens
on the team all the time.
But it is Bazel build.
For Blaze build if
you're inside Google.
The differences between
the products are minimal,
and we're trying to
eliminate them each day.
But man, historical
baggage is hard to unload.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's
really interesting, though.
So if I'm sitting down
for a new project, am I
thinking to myself, I'm
building a polyglot project,
so maybe I will lean
towards Bazel because I
have multiple languages.
Is that a contributing
factor to why
I might choose this as a tool?
TONY AIUTO: It could be, yes.
One of the things we
find talking to people
is you find people
from a community,
like the Go community.
The have a wonderful
set of tools
for building pure Go systems.
But once you start mixing
it with other languages,
and you want to
share, let's say,
a protobuf definition between
your Go and your C++ code,
then the pure Go
tools fall short.
I don't mean to pick on Go.
This is true for
every language that
has a very well-defined
set of development tools.
Once you start crossing
over to multilingual things,
that's where Blaze
really shines.
Because the single set
of build definitions
can define your entire product.
And you don't have to glue
together different systems
in some sort of shell script.
MARK MANDEL: Or Make
file, which is--
TONY AIUTO: Yeah, or Make file.
Right, the Make file to
call Gradle, to call Make.
MELANIE WARRICK: Gluing
together is always fun, though.
We love doing that.
TONY AIUTO: But it's hard
on your release engineers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Exactly.
Release engineers
love that, don't they?
Well, I know we talked already
a little bit about this,
but why would we choose this
over something like Make,
Maven, Gradle, whatever?
TONY AIUTO: Really,
to reduce the cost
of your daily development.
In a nutshell, that's
what the goal is.
You don't want to
switch to another system
because it looks nicer.
You want to do it
because you want
to make your developer's lives
better by giving them a faster
turnaround time.
And we do that through
this fact that each build
step is a hermetic action.
So we know that we don't have
to do it again a second time.
You change one file
in a Bazel build,
and we will only rebuild
those things that
absolutely have to get rebuilt.
We have capability to
hook into caching on a,
let's say, site-wide basis,
so that all your developers
at one site can share
each other's results.
So if you've all pulled down a
common bit of third-party code,
the first person who builds
it loses for the team.
They've waited.
Everyone else gets to
reuse the object module
that [INAUDIBLE] your teammates
incurred the cost of building.
So everyone goes
a little faster.
It's the incrementally,
good, reliable,
incremental builds
that speed everyone up.
We do the same thing
on the test side.
You change one bit,
and instead of having
to rerun 10,000 tests, we
may only have to rerun 20.
And you do that for enough
developers enough days,
and it turns into real money.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds
really interesting
from the perspective of it.
It seems like in today's
development environment,
you're no longer
pushing out a jar.
You're no longer just
pushing out a binary.
You're compiling
some code, and then
maybe bringing another
library, and putting that
into a Docker image, and
then taking that image
and doing stuff with that.
This sounds like
this sort of tool
that provides the glue between
the seven different things
that you need to pull together.
Would that be accurate?
TONY AIUTO: Yes, exactly.
We're not entirely
there yet, but you
should be able, at one
point, to define a role
to build a Docker image
and list inside it things
that were built in
different languages,
all assembled, multiple
binaries going into it,
with a single Blaze build--
Bazel build to target.
MELANIE WARRICK: (CHUCKLING)
I know, Blaze and Bazel.
It's easy to go back
and forth between those.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly, exactly.
TONY AIUTO: It is tricky
to keep those straight.
MELANIE WARRICK: But I know
you guys are probably so
used to it at this point.
It's pretty common that
you're just like, we get it.
We get it.
TONY AIUTO: Well, yeah.
11 years worth of muscle
memory, and they're
an anagram of each other.
And if you're slightly
dyslexic, it's possible.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So Bazel supports--
I'm going to just switch
between the two the whole time.
TONY AIUTO: "Basel" works, yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: No, I'm kind of
enjoying going "Basel" on one--
MARK MANDEL: Then "Basil"?
MELANIE WARRICK: --and
then "Basil" on another.
So Bazel supports
hermetic execution.
Does that mean I can
parallelize my work
load across lots of machines?
TONY AIUTO: Yes, absolutely.
Even on a single machine, we
try to parallelize it a bit,
in that your build builds a
graph of what needs to be done.
And then after the graph of what
needs to be done is computed,
we know exactly what execution
steps need to happen.
And the ones that don't
depend on each other
can be all done in parallel.
On a single machine, we
may only spin up for--
maybe 10 threads worth of
that, because we don't want
to deadlock your own machine.
But with a good remote
execution environment,
we can easily spin up 300,
400 threads of things that
can be executed in parallel.
Actually, the remote
build protocol
is published in a standard.
We have-- there's some
third parties working
on things that use this
remote build protocol,
their own kind of build farms.
Google has a product
that is alpha testing,
and it's in-- you can sign up
to try it right now, where we
provide remote build execution.
But someone could build their
own remote build server.
There are some
early Bazel adopters
who have their own strict
requirements about no code
off-prem.
So they want to build
their own remote executors
so that their code never
has to ship across the wire,
and they can keep it in-house.
These were all
possible, and they
can use Bazel to take
advantage of remote build,
even without using a
third-party cloud product.
MARK MANDEL: So I was
doing research on Bazel,
and we talked a bit before about
all the languages it supports.
It looks like some
of that support
comes through extensions,
or there's some kind
of extension mechanism there.
How does that work?
TONY AIUTO: One of the
key differentiators
between Google's
version of Blaze
and the new version
of Bazel is that rules
used to be built into the
Blaze execution, Blaze binary.
They are all in an
extension language in Bazel,
and the extension language
is called Starlark now.
It used to be Skylark, and that
has been renamed for reasons.
And there's a very
strict separation
between what a developer
at the high level
sees in a build file and
the rules that are written
in this extension language.
Starlark is Python-esque.
It looks very much like
Python when you write it,
with a few restrictions.
We don't allow
recursion, and since--
it's got a very similar syntax.
And at this point, I should
mention one of the things
that help make Bazel
accurate is its view of what
we have to build.
Every command-to-builder
testing is
done in three phases, where
we load up the things you need
and all the rules, which is
really just parsing and doing
things like visibility.
We can restrict
certain targets in the
build to a particular
set of other targets,
so that you can--
just like in any language, you
would do some object wrapping
to hide implementation
details, we
can hide targets from having
everyone in your organization
exploit the-- or use the things
you don't want to be seen.
That happens at load time.
Analysis time is
when we can execute
these Starlark
rules to determine
what our build graph should be.
And we can determine the
delta from the last version
of the build graph, so we
know what has to be built new.
And then finally, we get
to an execution phase,
where we can parallelize like
crazy to do only what we need
in the shortest time possible.
And this strict separation
also prevents this loop
where the results
of an execution
can feed back into
analysis later on.
I'm sure everyone listening has
had a project somewhere where
you run the Make twice in a row
and you get different results,
because the first time
leaves [INAUDIBLE]
that the second time picks up.
And that just doesn't happen
with Bazel-based products.
MARK MANDEL: So what kind of--
I mean, we talked about
language extensions.
But what kind of stuff do
people build with extensions?
What would people
want to do with that?
TONY AIUTO: Well, all of
our rule sets right now.
Well, C++ and Java are still
built into the Bazel core.
Python a bit too.
We're moving it out.
Rules Go is all built in
the extension language.
The JavaScript, the C# support.
[INAUDIBLE] is built in
the extension language.
Really, the Bazel team and
the larger Bazel community,
and outside companies,
are all contributing
sets of rules that really make
the Bazel ecosystem bigger
than the core Bazel
product itself.
MARK MANDEL: And so
as a company as well
who has a team of developers, we
could write our own extensions
that would help us do
specific things that
are particular to our
companies as well?
TONY AIUTO: Yeah.
Well, we can take the
Haskell Rules in particular.
There's a company
in France, Tweag,
I hope I'm pronouncing
it right, who
have done a lovely set of
rules for Haskell, because they
needed it for their
daily development.
And they contributed it
back to the outside world.
So they have other
people using their rules,
and it requires no modifications
to core Bazel itself.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
What do you enjoy most
about what you work on?
TONY AIUTO: Well, I've
been building and selling
developer tools for years.
And it's super gratifying
to go into a place
and have engineers
say, oh, I use this.
It makes my job easier.
So that's really what I
love about what I work on.
And I believe in it too,
because at Google, I've
shipped products that
were consumer-side.
And we really care
about the provenance
of what goes into our code.
And I think most
product-shipping companies do.
They have to know
everything that went in,
and they didn't accidentally
include a GPL code
in a product that's not
compatible with that.
Or if they did use an
[INAUDIBLE] library,
they linked it dynamically
rather than statically.
And that's really hard to know
with many ad hoc built systems.
But with Bazel, you
can actually trace down
the provenance of
everything you've included
and then script your own
checking against that,
to make sure that you know
what you are giving to people.
And that's really
one of the things
that motivated me to move from
my last team to the Bazel team.
MARK MANDEL: So what
products are actually
using Bazel right now?
I'm guessing there's probably
a lot of Google products
that probably use Bazel
that are open-source.
TONY AIUTO: Well, all Google
products, for the most part,
are built with the internal
version, called the Blaze.
And most of the
reason for that is
that internally, we have
some different packaging
requirements.
If we were shipping
to a Linux system,
someone might want a
Debian or RPM package.
Google has its own thing
that's different from that.
It's not that it's secret.
It's just our way
of doing things,
and there's no benefit in
sharing it with the world.
No benefit to the rest of the
world if we tried to share it.
So the Google version of
Blaze is built on Bazel,
with a few internal additions.
So really, all Google
products are using Bazel.
There are-- I can't
list customers directly,
but I can talk about the recent
BazelCon we had a few weeks ago
in New York.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
TONY AIUTO: We did have
nearly 200 external attendees
representing a hundred
different organizations
either currently using Bazel,
or evaluating it right now.
From large multinationals
to small start-ups.
Some organizations who
are very tight-lipped
about what they do.
What I can say is we've found
a real niche in organizations
that worry a lot about
compliance and re-certifying
what they're shipping.
And they love the fact that
they can test extensively
and accurately, and know
the provenance of everything
they've gone into.
So financial
institutions really like
people doing embedded devices
that go into various consumer
price products.
Love it as well for that reason.
But I should not
mention their names.
MARK MANDEL: No, no.
That's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MARK MANDEL: That
was a good answer.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
are resources and ways
that developers can
get started with Bazel?
TONY AIUTO: Going to our
website, Bazel.build,
and looking at one of
the starter quick starts
for various languages.
There is full documentation
of the product.
I say "product" because
I'm a product guy,
but of the "project" and
what the features are.
There is a discussion
group, Bazel Discuss,
on Google Groups.
And all the sources
available on GitHub--
I wouldn't recommend that as the
place to start figuring it out.
The website is the right place.
But the GitHub project does
contain many of the rules sets
that are built by the community.
So just looking
through that gives you
an idea of the
kind of support you
can expect, where you would
to want to adopt Bazel.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
What cool stuff is
coming in the future?
What can people
expect from Bazel?
TONY AIUTO: Well, we're
a 0 point right now.
We want to get to a
1.0 release in 2019.
And we haven't announced
a firm date yet.
MARK MANDEL: I understand
this well, yes.
Deliberately vague.
TONY AIUTO: It's not
that we aren't done,
that 1.0 is going to
last for five years.
[INAUDIBLE] come on,
new rules sets develop.
But the big thing
in ways Bazel 1.0
that will be a stability promise
and a way to inform users
well in advance of changes
that might be incompatible
and breaking, so that they
have a long time to migrate,
and it's very
easy, conceptually,
to figure out how to
migrate to newer versions.
We also want to bring the
rule-owners into that.
Because when we have Scala
rules, depending on the Java
rules, and they each
depend on Bazel,
it does the community no good if
the Scala rules and Java rules
each are built to depend on
a different version of Bazel.
So we want to get the community
behind phased releases,
so that end users don't
have any surprises.
And that's the big
guarantee for 1.0.
The rest of it is more
usable documentation.
Removing all nits that were
built in Google long ago,
and have been carried further
and we should have killed off.
So we're trying to get
those out of the project
now while we still can.
And then more rules.
That's more language support.
That's the short-term
future for Bazel.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
That sounds really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Tony, thank you so much for
coming on the podcast with us.
Is there anything
else that we didn't
cover you wanted to
touch on before we go?
TONY AIUTO: Not too much.
I pointed you to all the things.
People can find us in
the places I mentioned.
We're on a Slack
channel periodically.
The Slack group is
called Bazel Build.
I think we can share
a link to that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
TONY AIUTO: But too
hard to say off-hand,
so we can get it
onto the website.
I enjoyed being here
and had fun today.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well yeah, Tony, thank you so
much for spending time today
with us, and hanging
out on the podcast
and answering all our questions.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, thank you.
TONY AIUTO: You're welcome.
Have a good afternoon.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again to
Tony for joining us this week,
and especially thanks
to Tony for joining us
at the last minute.
We had to fill a
spot very quickly,
and we really appreciate
you taking the time
and giving us such
interesting information
about the Bazel project
and the open source backing
behind it, the reasoning,
and the history.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
So when we initially were
putting this together,
Mark and I were struggling
with Cool Things of the Week,
because we were in a bit
of, as I mentioned earlier--
MARK MANDEL: A funk.
MELANIE WARRICK: --a mood.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: But we do have
some Cool Things of the Week,
and I do want to take
a minute to recognize
that, which is why
we are recording
this the second time around.
This is officially Mark's
third year for the podcast.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: [CHUCKLING]
MELANIE WARRICK:
We're at that point.
MARK MANDEL: Hello.
MELANIE WARRICK: You and
Francesc started this.
MARK MANDEL: We did.
Hi, Francesc.
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Francesc.
I'm saying you and Mark.
Both of you.
MARK MANDEL: You
should feel proud too.
MELANIE WARRICK: But yeah, you
are at your three-year mark,
which is incredible.
And this is 153
podcasts that you
have worked on, with one
exception, because I did one
without you.
MARK MANDEL: There
was a few also
that Francesc did without me.
MELANIE WARRICK: That
Francesc did without you?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
So fine, maybe it's
150 total for you.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: But
still, three years.
Long time.
Amazing.
MARK MANDEL: (SNORTING)
What have I done?
MELANIE WARRICK: I don't
know what you've done.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Close
to 2 million downloads
at this point.
[CASH REGISTER CHIMING]
So I'm going to go ahead
and give that one away.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Just want
to give you a bit kudos.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
people should tweet at you
or say something to
you like "congrats,"
if you're out there listening.
MARK MANDEL: How nice.
It's been quite a
ride, that never stops.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Nope, it doesn't.
It never does.
You can never, never stop.
MARK MANDEL: But thanks
to everyone who's listened
through that time
period as well.
It couldn't be possible without
the audience participation,
the audience listening.
So thanks to
everyone who listens.
And we love it when
we get messages.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
MARK MANDEL: And
people wander up
and they're like,
oh my god, you're
the people from the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
The--
MARK MANDEL: Sometimes
they even remember my name.
But it's-- (CHUCKLING)
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
The feedback has been amazing by
the community that's listening.
The other thing
we wanted to note
that we realized
we'd forgotten about
is it's Halloween on the day
that this is being released.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's true.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's
Halloween in the States, which
I think has now infiltrated
the rest of the world.
MARK MANDEL: It's a few places.
MELANIE WARRICK: I've been
in Japan once for Halloween,
and it's pretty
impressive what they do.
MARK MANDEL: If you like
dressing up and eating candy,
please go ahead.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
So hopefully you're
having a good time
and you're having some fun.
Ooh, I'd like to see
people's costumes.
So yeah, those are the
two things we especially
wanted to mention.
We do have a couple
on things on GCP.
Mark, did you want
to kick it off?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So let's go into the
actual Cool Things
of the Week for the GCP side.
So there are a few new and
interesting announcements.
So there's the new
Asset Inventory
System that's available.
If you're responsible
for managing,
basically, your organization's
cloud resources, maybe you
have lots of projects
with different app engine
stuff in it, with different
billing accounts, storage
buckets, et cetera,
trying to consolidate
all of what you have and
manage that all can be actually
kind of tricky and hard.
So we've started
this whole thing
called the Asset
Inventory System that
provides an API that will
enable you to do that.
If you actually
have a look, we'll
put a link in our blog post,
but there's examples there
of how you can hit the API.
It is the first pass.
There's going to be
some more stuff coming.
So definitely
check it out if you
do manage those kinds
of very large workloads.
MELANIE WARRICK: And then one
of our colleagues, Seth Fargo,
has written up a post on
introducing the Cloud KMS
plugin for HashiCorp Vault.
And so HashiCorp Vault
is an open-source tool
for secrets management.
It's very popular with
many of our customers.
And so the Cloud KMS Vault users
can manage their cloud KMS keys
now, encrypt and decrypt
data, and sign verified data
using the familiar Vault API.
There's a number of
features and benefits
that he's shared, like
familiar APIs, authentication
and authorization, and
privileged and Cipher text
upgrades.
And I don't know exactly what
this is, but Phipps 142 Level 3
certification.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure it's good.
MELANIE WARRICK: So I'm
sure it's important.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MELANIE WARRICK: Something
to do around encryption
and decryption.
So yeah, you can
check out the post
and see what that's all about.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it
looks pretty easy to set up
from the post, which is great.
MELANIE WARRICK: I agree.
MARK MANDEL: Speaking
of teammates,
our friend from last
week, Martin Omander,
a cloud developer advocate,
continued his series
on Serverless from
the ground up .
And they've done a really neat
job wherein what they're doing
is connecting a spreadsheet
to their document management
system, and making--
basically, making a
Google Drive spreadsheet.
The UI for how you
interact with the system.
which is really nice
for business users.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
And then not a
GCP thing, but I'm
going to give a shout
out to myself, which
is I just posted a blog, I
haven't done very many lately,
about understanding
cybersecurity
for previous generations.
So not the next generation,
but the previous generation.
Because I know many
of us are probably
tech support for our
parents or grandparents.
And so understanding
some of the things
that you need to keep aware of
to help them stay safe online.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
we'll include a link
in the show notes, as we do
with all the other things.
MARK MANDEL: I'm going to
send this to my parents.
This is really good.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well great.
You can also read it for you
to help with your parents.
That's the goal.
I actually wrote
this down, because I
was like-- even though you
and I are not sports fans,
i figured we should give a
shout out to the Red Sox.
Which it's kind of
a thing for them,
especially, to be
winning the World Series,
which is wonderful.
And I just want to
give them a congrats.
MARK MANDEL: Baseball.
Yay, baseball.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yay.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: So they won the
World Series this last weekend.
MARK MANDEL: Where
are you going?
What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm going
to be at an unconference
known as [INAUDIBLE]
at the end of November.
And what about you?
MARK MANDEL: November, I'm
going on vacation for a bit.
Yes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Good.
You need it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
December, I will be
speaking at Cube-Con, which
I'm also very excited about.
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm happy
for you going to Cube-Con.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, I think
that's it for us this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So Melanie, thank
you for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: I thank
you all for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[THEME MUSIC]